mais c'est le dossier important une
relance et l'île de la tentation
alors marie oui vous êtes avec nous vous
êtes très joli et moi je suis toujours
je vais pas vous mentir je suis toujours
l esb hobby pour lire tous les jours et
la copie voir des gens qui viennent
tester tester leur amour dans une
émission qui s'appelle l'île de la
tentation c'est vrai la comprend pas moi
je vois où j'avoue que je ne comprends
pas la volonté d'aller fracassé son
couple parce qu'on est à peu près tous
pareils si on passe quinze jours sur une
île avec des bo gars ou des belles nanas
pour bahia climat risque que ça dérape
[Rires]
surtout pas moi et surtout pas à
débourser
voilà voilà viadeo qui nous regarde je
vous rappelle alors donc vous vous étiez
avec avec julien depuis quand depuis
depuis six mois cinq ministres étaient
fréquents et donc vous avez eu envie
d'aller tester votre amour pour quelle
raison parce que j'ai 42 ans et je me
suis dit j'ai plus de temps à perdre car
on voulait faire vous avez 25 ans et les
bras faute alors alors quoi alors moi
juste comment est-ce que la production
vous avons été ou est ce que c'est vous
pouvez contacter n'y en a pas c'est moi
qui ai eu d'accord mais la démarche de
contacter la production et j'ai eu envie
d'aller essayer je me suis dit j'ai plus
de temps à perdre moi on va là-bas et si
vraiment vous êtes vous avez perdu votre
temps parce que j'ai tout perdu en même
temps puisque visiblement julien et a
trouvé une autre chaussure à son pied
vous mettiez pas certaine de juillet à
la base donc non annoncés papa mais
j'avais des doutes quand même et il
était au cas par cas la différence d'âge
en fait il est jeune je me dis qu'il n'a
pas eu encore d'expérience il a
peut-être envie s'amuser encore est ce
forcément c était le temps il était
partant dès le départ ah oui elle est
belle oui je pense qu'il était pas
justement vous allez voir julien c'était
c'était la semaine dernière et la
semaine dernière et bien c'est le drame
nanananère tu veux que je t'en avec ta
c'est ça parce que quand georges feydeau
je te mérite pas mais question tu mettes
je rejoins moi dans ma vie parce que tu
m'as demandé où je dormais je dorme avec
jamais
dames
donc ça m'a pas beau et nommé charles et
vous riez c'est là donc c'est un drame
quand même donc c'est un drame
donc en fait tu tu as a forcément on est
convoqué au fameux volcan est là avec
avec eux je vais taton qui pose plein de
questions mais essentiellement la même
question et la vidéo et voulez-vous voir
ces images elle vous demande oui bah oui
mais juliette est l'objet de garder une
distance avec nous pour avancer dans nos
choix c'est normal que les cette
distance avec 9 hélas hélas hélas au feu
de camp vous découvrez ces images et on
vous demande est ce que vous voulez voir
ces images mais ou non
du
je
qu'est ce que tu as vu l'ancien
moi je
je viens qui est dans la chambre avec la
fille qui l'embrassé
il cache la caméra
n'a pas l'air de se faire la même chose
d'avoir vu ces images
[Musique]
c'est la suite logique donc je me suis
préparé en vue
images douloureuses mais après mes
émotions je préfère les
vivre seul parce que j'ai ma dignité
ma fierté
je peux je vois toutes les femmes qui
mouillent hommes sur le pac man dans la
profession on va être vraiment eu
est ce que vous êtes tellement à ce que
vous n'avez pas bien comment ça s'est
fini c'est d'être parti ensemble rouge
et perd notre côté que ça à la fin quand
même s'ils repartent et vous ensemble ou
non nous avons pouvait pas répondre aux
pêches paribas répond non jean comtois
contrat parce qu'on voyait qu'on
travaille c'est aussi un des tous voilà
quelques années alors déjà pourquoi vous
l'avez fait pour pour être sûrs ou non
de lui ben oui puis pendant la vérité
sur fait gagner du temps à ce moment là
dans l'émission je suis je suis plus sûr
à ce moment là forcément elle a gagné
combien d'argent pour ça par exemple à
la scène question indique cette discrète
bélier déclencher la sélection des
candidates elle va à bâle elsa gratot
non non non moi je pense que les
défrayer milan la semaine croit marie
bien mg a fait une belle semaine mon
mari répondez-moi à l'étroit dans les
franches pour jouer qu'une femme et
quatre cinq mois 3 mai bal la semaine
nourris logés et des mes photos de moi
non mais c'est pour ça aussi qu'on l'a
on dirait qu'on n'avait pas très
affectés on a franchement marre images
où dit on a l'impression que c'est de la
comédie complète n'ont pas donc vous
dites moi combien il avait touché
dites moi elle est possible dites-moi
est-ce que vous étiez vraiment je
répondais fait que vous êtes en prison
m'a affecté non en fait j'ai 42 ans et
les murs les plus gros de ma vie je
l'avais pris mais vous avez l'âge et le
père de ma fille qui m'a quitté deux ans
et demi auparavant et ça m'a fait très
très mal donc
après je pense que quand on est passé
par là on se blinde et donc j'ai moins
de réactions que par rapport aux jeunes
qui ont 25 26 ans qui a envie de tout
casser qui partent en live c'est
différent j'ai plus de recul mois sur la
situation
il ya quand même un truc qui me fait
dire que vous êtes un faux couple pardon
je pense qu'on va pas faire trembler la
république mais moi c'est ce que je
pense
j'y crois pas à votre couple pourquoi
parce que vous avez créé votre profil
instagram en même temps que vous avez
passé les castings vous alors c'est très
bizarre et en plus je vous ai entendu
dire que vous saviez qu'il allait vous
trompez donc moi j'y crois pas après
vous avez real
vous allez augmenter c'est la réponse
que je pense juste chez médium et c'est
vrai qu'avant de partir dans l'aventuré
voulait me voir je me suis réveillé et
je dis je sens que tu vas faire
effondrer avec une blonde aucun tatouage
changera avec damas justement alors
justement jour d'étoilés et adouma dma
des bêtises parce que figurez vous qu'au
moment où les tentateurs et tentatrices
ont été dévoilées quand vous avez vu les
filles j'aimais les techniques sont
regardés un flash me suis dit c est long
[Musique]
ce à l'embauché pour toi tu crois j'ai
tout de suite vu de style de femme pour
julien celle qui m'a fait peur c'est
celle qui avait le maillot barbouch avec
les cheveux longs blonds un petit
surfeuse un tatouage comme julien bon
voilà tous les critères qui peuvent
faire que
mais après on parle d'un physique et
on sait pas ce qu'il ya derrière
mon chien c'est important mais c'est
vrai qu'il va gêner un gourmand qu'on
lâche dans une boulangerie
mais marie a quand même de gros doutes
moi je les dis ici sur les couples je
connais j'ai enquêté sur un des couples
je sais que c'est un couple de
télévision ils sont venus là parce que
un des deux membres du couple veut faire
de la télé se faire reconnaître
et oui même mtf beaucoup d'émissions
donc ce sont quand même des habitués qui
s'est beaucoup démené on est forcément
un couple fait pour en revenir sur
l'installera francesca en fait j'ai un
instagram perso mais j'ai des enfants et
à partir moment et l'émission allait
sortir j'avais pas envie qu'on voit mes
enfants donc j'ai forcément créer un
autre instagram
voilà pourquoi on voir ici on va
vraiment dans votre sens ok admettons
que vous soyez vraiment un vrai couple
oui on est à voir
d'accord vous êtes un vrai couple
pourquoi est-ce que vous infliger une
telle humiliation vous avez une chance
sur deux pour qu'il vous trompez et en
plus vous avez des doutes
avec le mec elle voulait plus de dix
jours or normalement on avait pardon
excusez moi mais attention je vais dire
quelque chose de concret pour une fois
vous abonner vacants mais bara tall est
sortie du jeu moi je les ai contactés et
marie elle peut le dire je n'ai pas
signé en fait elle ne fait pas placement
produit le c0 placement de produit donc
ce que vous êtes en train de dire là sur
son compte instagram c'est faux et je
suis la preuve on sait que c'est faux
puisque sinon elle aurait déjà commencé
et attention ceux qui sortent comment ce
n'est pas son prix pas forcément ils
n'ont pas fait la télé pour faire de
l'argent ça n'a rien à voir mais en tout
cas en ce pont sainte marie et les
préjugés qu'on peut avoir sur les
candidats de télé réalité
la preuve que c'est faux puisqu'elle n'a
toujours pas fait de placements produits
et je les contacte époux madoff
est-ce que c'est l'elysée qui veut pas
vendre n'importe wall street a dit
ouverte et plus d'émission dida non non
les autres candidats j'ai j'en ai qui
sont très bons et qu'ils sont très
bankable
il ya la promenade su seulement quand on
dit qu'ils vont faire ça pour ça la
preuve c'est fort est d'accord alors
juste c'est vrai que dans cette mission
excusez moi vous été infléchie quand
même beaucoup de souffrance qui est une
des premières images
et puis d'autres et à chaque fois vous
vous y retourner pourquoi un bandonéon
voir les images mais pour qu'on dit pas
un mot ne dit pas à son mec qui vous de
battance arrêt stop on se casse est la
même pour moi je t'ai maersk et
mais face à qui il a offert à man il ya
des caractères différents
on voit mal et qui a aimé dit par
exemple médiers tient plus il la demande
en confrontation il s'en va chaque
caractère est différent il ya des gens
qui ont tendance à encaisser mieux que
les autres et aller jusqu'au bout des
choses et voir jusqu'au bout il va aller
vous franchement vous encaissez bien
là
[Musique]
on sait pas on sait pas si en fait ces
crimes ou lille c'est pas si mal
emmanchée sous le choc quand même alors
on a on a vu ça mais ce qui est amusant
et c'est un peu le point de l'émission
c'est que en voyant ça vous marie vous
allez jeter votre regard sur marin marin
marais ou pas ces gens qui nous
regardent
vas-y alors cessé la fête si j'ai rien
fait moi je parle avec marc legrand est
on est on a les images je suis
malheureux ne leur vient pas le petit
bain c'est une vengeance
qu'est ce que ça a de l'amour l'attrait
conforter marin est là et beaucoup on
s'entend bien mieux vous savez ce qu'ils
vous savez ce qu'on dit marie femme qui
rit à moitié dans son lit et avec avec
marin j'ai beaucoup rigolé
alors en défaut je dirais trop gentil
oui parce que là encore aujourd'hui
regard est éteint quand la bourse aux
autres et touche tous que c'est presque
pas ce à quoi m aux lentilles jetables
trois connards
d'ailleurs j'attends j'en vois pas
beaucoup parce qu'on s'entend super bien
ça c'est vrai on le voit un travail a
fait défaut c'est parce que ça fait
quand même un petit peu bizarre de voir
marie toujours avec avec ces mêmes
garçons en fait dans ma position
actuelle je pense que je peux pas trop
parler à savoir que je m'entendais avec
mélanie donc les deux côtés c'est un peu
pareil alors quand même excusez moi je
sais pas je ne porte pas de jugement
mais votre vengeance alive très vite
alors certes tel montage mais c'est vrai
que le sentiment qu'on a tous un peu ici
c'est que votre couple
ils y allaient pour le moment il est
quand même
il est quand même un peu fragile quoi
forcément il est fragile il ya un peu
plus fragile que des personnes qui sont
ensemble depuis des mois
où est obama au bout de sept ans
généralement je change par exemple le
bouton d'une boutade
et sans aller à l'avant apporte
également des six mois c'est à paris
c'est sur les quais de seine échange de
questions salazie sur vous étiez en
couple avec un ingé aux deux clubs de
vacances c'est ça ou pas oui je sais ça
c'est donc séduire mon autre question
parce qu'on va pas se voit pas se mentir
tout à l'heure gill a évoqué vous avez
déjà fait plusieurs plusieurs si je suis
en télé c'est quoi les missions de votre
rêve et qui fait que qu'aujourd'hui vous
vous êtes en mode vous voulez vous
exposer comme ça en télé c'est à dire
mission vous rêveriez d'intégrer motus
pour les bulls
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment de six mois mais on vous voit
pas la télé non j'ai pas du contraire
accorder la paf il allait l'émission lbg
otba touche pas à mon poste
oui moi j'ai deux questions la boîte
vous médium
pourquoi est-ce qu avant même d'aller à
l'île de la tentation vous n'avez pas vu
que votre maison les médiums on voit pas
forcément tout pour nous séduire
d'abord on doit consulter en revanche on
a quelques flash ça arrive comme ça
m'est arrivé avant de partir dans l'
aventure avec julien la veille j'ai eu
ce flash où je lui ai dit oulala je
crains qu'ils aient une fille comme ci
comme ça c'est avec elle je vais avoir
des problèmes mais après oui tu pars en
fonction de ce que je ressens aussi
parce que je comme cartésienne à la base
même si j'ai ce don et du coup je vis ma
vie je vais pas vu en fonction c'est la
deuxième question pardon la deuxième
question qui rejoint un peu celle de
ludivine vous avez fait tellement
démission c'est une question qu'on se
pose nous toujours à touche pas à mon
poste
comment qu'est ce qui se passe dans la
tête de quelqu'un comme vous belle jeune
femme qui fait autant d'émissions c'est
pour se faire voir
c'est pour l'argent c'est pour exister à
la loi c'est à reconnaître ces libres de
l'argent pour se faire voir en fait on
est venu chercher et c'est à des moments
de ma vie où j'étais à la maison je veux
m'occuper de mes enfants je ne
travaillais pas énormément et ça
m'occupe et et les sujet m'intéressait
parce que c'était du vécu donc si je
trouve ça intéressant de partager
par exemple j'ai fait un sujet sur la
famille recomposée où moi je m'entends
très bien avec mes ex mari et voilà ce
que c'est que la semaine prochaine
ouais je me rappelle la semaine
prochaine avait vu merci à eux
[Rires]
super bravo
alors je dois vous dire c'était ce
projet nous vous en prenez un petit coup
derrière la tête eux dans la tête bah
oui ben hiba regarder samassa fait les
f-15 qu'ils ont changé
tu as demandé une confrontation avec ta
fiancée molly
je vais pas venir
si elle ne vient pas chez
j'aurai la réponse la plus radicale de
match
maurice
en fait clairement je suis en train de
me posais pas la question étant témoin
l'a réellement dépassé les limites
et marie n'existe plus
[Musique]
ne pas la voir
je me rends compte que ben là avec ces
propos s'ils voilà cette vidéo la
voulait pas la boîte